digamos que tenemos aquí un vaso que va
a contener algún líquido no
necesariamente agua aquí tiene un
líquido y esta es su superficie ya
aprendimos que la presión en cualquier
punto de este líquido va a depender de
qué tan profundo nos sumerjamos en él y
un punto que quiero hacer notar antes de
continuar y ya lo he mencionado antes es
que la presión en un punto
no sólo va a estar actuando hacia abajo
o en una sola dirección sino que actúa
en todas direcciones ya que este
elemento este si imaginemos que aquí
tenemos una partícula si está quieta
quiere decir que todas las fuerzas a su
alrededor las fuerzas netas son cero así
que no importa qué tan profundo
lleguemos la presión va a actuar en
todas direcciones incluyendo arriba y la
razón de que esto tenga sentido es que
asumiendo que este sea un sistema
estático o que el líquido esté
estacionario o que hay un objeto aquí
dentro y está estacionario el hecho de
que no se esté moviendo nos dice que la
presión en todas direcciones
es la misma imaginemos por ejemplo una
molécula de agua que es más o menos
esférica
y las presiones sobre esta molécula de
agua fueran diferentes
y estos son vector citas que están
simulando las presiones
esta molécula si está por ejemplo que va
de arriba hacia abajo fuera más grande
esta presión entonces el objeto
comenzaría a acelerarse hacia abajo ya
que el área que está aquí arriba es
igual al área que va aquí abajo la
fuerza que va hacia abajo sería mayor
así que aún cuando la presión es una
función de qué tan profundo estamos en
cierto punto la presión va a estar
actuando en todas direcciones
así que recordemos esto y tengamos lo
presente para aprender algo nuevo
imaginemos que vamos a sumergir en este
líquido un cubo más o menos así
permítanme dibujar el cubo aquí afuera
para que lo podamos ver con más claridad
este cubo lo estoy sumergiendo en este
líquido que se encuentra en este vaso
y las dimensiones de este cubo son de x
de borde
y lo que quiero hacer es encontrar cuál
es la fuerza neta en el cubo sumergido
pensemos cómo es la presión en este cubo
en diferentes puntos la presión a los
lados del cubo es la misma y se cancelan
mutuamente pero algo que sí sabemos es
que la presión va a estar en función de
la profundidad es decir que la presión
aquí abajo en este punto va a ser más
alta que la presión que se encuentra
aquí arriba y ya que la base estará más
profunda que la parte superior
vamos a llamar esta presión que se
encuentra aquí arriba presión superior
s
y la presión que se encuentra aquí abajo
va a ser la presión inferior superior e
inferior y cuál será la fuerza neta en
este objeto o en este como bueno la
fuerza neta efe n va a ser igual a la
presión inferior que es la fuerza que
actúa desde abajo del objeto y cuál va a
ser el área de esta parte inferior de
este objeto bueno pues va a ser de
cuadrada ya que este objeto es un cubo
su área de la cara inferior va a ser un
cuadrado el área de un cuadrado por lo
que aquí esto lo vamos a multiplicar por
d cuadrada y hago esto porque ya sé que
la presión inferior va a ser mayor que
la presión superior por eso estoy
poniendo la de este lado porque voy a
restar la fuerza que actúa en la parte
superior
y que la fuerza neta y hacia arriba por
eso que pueda hacer esta resta con
confianza entonces tengo esto menos la
presión hacia abajo la presión que actúa
en la parte superior cuál es esta fuerza
también va a ser la presión de la parte
superior por el área en la que está
actuando que también es el área de un
cuadrado ya que esto es un cubo y de
hecho podemos factorizar esta de
cuadrada voy a aprovechar que ya la
tengo escrita aquí quedaría de cuadrada
por presión inferior menos la presión
superior y esto es igual a la fuerza
neta
y ahora vemos si podemos calcular estas
presiones digamos que este cubo está
sumergido
h unidades o h metros en este líquido
cuál va a ser la presión superior bueno
sabemos que la presión vamos a escribir
la presión superior es igual a la
densidad de este líquido multiplicado
por la profundidad por lo que va a estar
multiplicado por h
por hache y estará multiplicado por la
gravedad y cuál será la presión inferior
la presión inferior va a ser igual
también a la densidad
de líquido por la profundidad aquí la
profundidad en este punto va a ser esta
h más
lo que mide de lado este cubo por lo que
es de entonces va a estar x
h + b
y finalmente multiplicado por la
gravedad
ahora vamos a sustituir estas presiones
en esta fórmula por lo que nos va a
quedar que la fuerza neta es igual a de
cuadrada por la presión inferior que es
la densidad
x
h
por g menos la presión superior que es
también la densidad del líquido por la
altura
por la gravedad vamos a desarrollar un
poco más esta parte inferior ésta es
igual a de cuadrada por distribuimos row
por h por g más
por de por g - ron por h por g y podemos
simplificar esto vemos que aquí hay un
menos roache g más roache que estos dos
se van y nos queda esto como si
multiplicamos la de cuadrada por este
término nos queda ro
al cubo porque y que desde al cubo a
pues de al cubo es el volumen de este
cubo y también es el volumen del líquido
desplazado al poner este cubo en este
líquido y ustedes habrán notado que el
nivel del líquido sube porque el mismo
volumen de este líquido es desplazado
para que pueda entrar el cubo así que
está de kubica es el volumen es el
volumen volumen
líquido desplazado
voy a hacer un poco de espacio para que
alcance a escribir que es el volumen de
líquido desplazado
desplazado
es la densidad del líquido y g es la
gravedad así que nos queda volumen por
densidad por gravedad el volumen por la
densidad es la masa del objeto por lo
que la fuerza neta la fuerza neta
también se escribe como masa por
gravedad y que es la masa por gravedad
pues la fuerza neta va a ser igual al
peso del objeto esto va a ser igual al
peso del objeto y el peso del líquido
el líquido desplazado
esto es algo bastante interesante si
sumergimos cualquier cosa en un líquido
la fuerza neta acumulada hacia arriba va
a ser igual al peso del agua que está
siendo desplazada y a esto se le llama
el principio de arquímedes pues la
fuerza neta hacia arriba debido al hecho
de que hay más presión en la base que en
la parte superior a eso le llamamos
fuerza de flotabilidad y es lo que hace
que las cosas flote hasta que lleguemos
en este vídeo para que puedan
reflexionar al respecto y usaremos este
concepto en los siguientes vídeos para
resolver algunos problemas